joining me today is a leader a follower
a reader a writer a speaker a listener a
student a teacher
Jaakko willing welcome to the Rubin
report that was that I took that right
out of the bio that's good right out of
the Twitter bio that's my Twitter bio
yeah yeah I'm a Twitter bot you're a
little bit of everything that actually
is a pretty good explanation of you it
actually it actually is a pretty good
explanation to me
I think I'm cover those multiple
dichotomies fairly well yeah that would
probably explain why you've written
roughly 37 thousand books right how
about how many books have you written I
mean I'd normally only put one book on
the table we slips for he's written so
far written three adult books yeah and
three kids books I've got another kid's
book coming out in the spring and I've
got another adult book coming out going
head-to-head with Jordan Peterson in
January of 20 2000 I probably will be on
tour with him for that book that means
that we're gonna be in competition okay
bring it uh-oh all right we'll see we'll
see
okay so nice to to not actually have to
compete with ya
well do you do you feel like you're in
competition with anyone it's that's an
interesting place to start off well
that's I guess there's a dichotomy there
too because I don't feel like I'm in
competition with anyone and I feel like
I'm in competition that's just sort of
you know in my nature to just compete
but no I mean in this world that I'm in
right now I don't really feel like I'm
competing with anyone I feel like I'm
just kind of doing what I do talking
about what I like to talk about writing
about what I like to write about and
hanging out with cool people most the
time yeah pretty good pretty good
all right well I think 99% of my
audience knows who you are knows a lot
about you but for the people that don't
and by the way I should say me right
before we started I was saying we have
been trying to coordinate this for about
27 years right I mean a long time which
is kind of funny I mean it it really
says it's like well we're two people
that are better busy yeah it was hard to
hard to really make this happen but for
the people that know nothing about you
tell me a little bit about your history
I was born and raised in a small New
England town I was a rebellious kid my
best way to rebel as a kid coming from a
small New England town was to join the
millage
so I joined the military after high
school I spent 20 years in the military
and when I retired from the military I
started taking the things that I had
learned from the military and teaching
them to civilian companies and civilian
leaders and eventually that turned into
a bulk in a podcast and all this other
stuff yeah so tell me a little bit more
about what you were like that made you
want to go into the military what was
that rebellious kid or whatever that
yeah you know I just grew up you know in
a little New England town and there was
a lot of hippies and just kind of kids
like that running around and smoking pot
and whatever and I really wasn't into
that and so you know I got think a lot
of kids when they rebel as kids because
all kids rebelle a lot of kids repelled
by drinking or they do drugs or whatever
they're gonna do and I went the other
direction was like into hardcore music
and eventually said oh yeah I'm just
gonna join the military because that's
what I'm gonna do yeah it's funny when
you talk about it it almost sounds like
you're slightly dismissing it but you
have it you had a pretty good storied
career as a Navy SEAL yeah no I grew up
in the SEAL Teams I went riding the Navy
right in the SEAL Teams
and that's where I spent my my whole
adult life and it was a incredible
experience worked with a bunch of
awesome people and got to do things that
I had dreamed about doing since I was a
little kid well what should we know
about like the life of a Navy SEAL that
you don't get in the movies or or
however else we just sort of imagine
these lives to be I would say the
biggest thing to remember is is that
that people in the SEAL Teams and people
in the military in general they're
people they're just normal people they
go home they got wives they got kids
they're trying to live a normal life and
then their job requires them to do
things that aren't very normal and so
they you know for me I kind of learned
to compartmentalize what I was doing in
the military and when I'd come home now
is I tell us to police officers and
firefighters and military guys today
don't when you get home don't bring your
uniform home don't wear your uniform
home like physically change your take
your uniform off leave it at work put on
your your civilian clothes and you go
home and be a civilian we
how hard is that though once you're sort
of in that locked mindset which
obviously has so much to do with the
things that you write about and why your
message actually is is working and
helping people you say how hard is it it
can be hard it can be hard you know
because you've got one life that you're
living where decisions are really
consequential and then you've got your
regular life that you're living and
things aren't that they aren't as
consequential you know I had a situation
where I was at work and there was a lot
of stuff going on at work they were they
were redeploying people to Afghanistan
there was big decisions that were being
made at work and I remember I came home
from work one day and like I said try to
try to leave my work at work but I'm
sitting there thinking about how all the
stuff is gonna unfold and my wife you
know I got home and my wife because I
can't believe this and I was like what
happened is everything okay and she says
you know the no it's not okay the the
Disney on Ice is the same night some
other dance for the kids and I'm
thinking hey if that's if that's the
biggest worries my wife has then that's
a positive thing ten life's pretty good
yeah life's pretty good yeah so how
quickly did you realize that you wanted
to sort of bring these ideas about
personal responsibility and sort of
owning your life and all that into sort
of that world
the world where Disney on Ice Matters a
mess of it yeah it's I was about six
months from retiring I had a friend that
was the CEO of a big company and he said
I want you to come and talk to my
executives about combat leadership and I
said hey sure you know sounds sounds
cool so I went and did it
and when I got and I don't think he
really knew what to expect you know
because I'm look like a knuckle-dragger
and a least a good portion I actually am
a knuckle-dragger
and so we bring me in the talk and I
thought I think he was maybe thinking I
tell some cooler stories and that'd be
that'd be great
but I actually started talking about how
you lead and when I got done he came up
to me and said I want you to do this for
every division that I have in my company
and I said well you know I'm retiring
and he said well I'll give you money and
I said
okay so I started working with all the
different divisionals
and at one of those division meetings
the CEO of the parent company was there
and when I got done he came up to me and
said I want you to come and talk to all
my CEOs for all these companies that
Helen and he owned like 45 or 50
companies so I went and did that and
when I went and talked to those
companies of course then a bunch of
those CEOs came up to me and said hey I
want you to come and talk to my company
so that's kind of the way that it
started and it didn't take me very long
at all I mean it it actually was the
very first company that first guy that I
talked to when they started when that
group started telling me about the
problems they were having I was sitting
there thinking myself well that's all
these problems in the steel platoons
when I was training steel platoons this
is the same thing it's leadership yeah
were you surprised that the big
successful businesses were having such a
leadership crisis I was surprised for
about five minutes and then I realized
that these are all human beings these
are the same human beings that are in a
seal platoon in an army company and in a
business and they're all they all have
the same idiosyncrasies that they have
the same egos the same personalities you
can see it all and when you've seen it
all over and over again it becomes
pretty evident pretty clear when you're
looking at it and the last job that I
have my SEAL Teams I was training while
running the SEAL training for the West
Coast SEAL Teams and this isn't a
training where you see like the guys
carrying the boats on their heads and
carrying logs around and doing a bunch
of push-ups and stuff the training that
I ran was the training where seals
actually learned to go into combat and
fight the enemy and this is where we
really start focusing on combat
leadership and so in this training that
I ran we got to take seal platoons and
put them through really tough training
scenarios very realistic training
scenarios over and over and over again
so every night I basically be putting a
new seal platoon through another
training scenario which the next night
will be another seal platoon going
through the same training scenario and
then the next time be another seal
platoon going through the same Chinese
snare so you take these different seal
tunes and what's different about a seal
platoon what's different about a seal
platoon is really just boils down to the
leadership because we've got 16 seals
and a seal guys are basically the same
sure there's some there's a bell curve
there's some top-end performers there's
low-end performers there's a bunch of
guys in the middle so the real variation
on their performance was based almost on
a percent on their on their leadership
in fact it was a hundred percent on
their leadership
so I got to see this and I got to watch
these leadership scenarios unfold over
and over again and see what leadership
things worked and what didn't work and
and so by the time I left that job and
entered the civilian sector I'd watched
some random team of leaders inside of my
organization
and I'd say no - all their strategic
Master doesn't get it down to the
frontline troops they need to
communicate this better or o their
departments aren't working together they
need to cover move for each other or
their mission is way too complex and
that no one has any idea what they're
actually supposed to be doing so they
need to simplify this or that this
senior leader is making all the
decisions and therefore everything's
moving really slow and nothing's
happening at a good rate of speed so
they need to use decentralized matter
and it was just so obvious when I
started how much of leadership in
general do you think is innate vs.
learned obviously you're teaching people
the learn part but there has to be some
element that's an aid right yeah there
absolutely is and there's the the
analogy that I give and I don't play
video games but I've seen it but on
video games there's you have a character
in a video game and you'll have a
certain level of intelligence is a
certain level of strength and a certain
level of agility and those levels are
what you get and then you work with well
it's the same thing for a leader and
there's different there's different
characteristics that you get that are
good for leadership right if you're
someone that's really articulate that's
a great thing to have to be a good
leader because you want the human beings
if you're talking to to understand what
you're actually saying so and different
people are naturally more articulate
than other people mm-hmm it's good to be
able to look at complex problems and be
able to simplify them right that's a
that's a very powerful tool to have a
really complex thing to solve and be
able to look at it and say okay simplify
it and then simplify it not only for
yourself so you can decide what to do
but simplify it for your team so they
understand what to do hmm that's that's
a characteristic that some people have
the the one that I bring up a lot
because it's very obvious is is being
loud because if you're in a leadership
position you need to be able to make
people hear you and some people are born
with a very loud voice I was luckily
born with a very loud voice and it's
inherited from my genes right and my
kids inherited it my kids are all can be
very loud which is so
time's problematic you know but if you
can't bark a command so that people can
hear you in a machine-gun fight no one's
be able to do what you ask them to do
yeah so there's these different
characteristics and you can improve upon
them so if you're not very articulate
you can read and you can write and you
can speak and you become more articulate
if you are not very good at simplifying
problems you can start looking at
complex problems and thinking about how
you can simplify them and you can get
better at that the being loud part is
that there's a definitely a genetic
aspect of that so sure you can learn to
project your voice more but some people
aren't very loud they're just born that
way and so what does a person do in that
situation well what a person does in
that situation is when they have to give
an order they tell one of the loud
mouths in their platoon to tell everyone
to get over in this other building now
and that loud mouth will pass a word and
so what you do is the leaders you find
members for your team that can
complement your weaknesses so there are
parts that you can improve and there are
parts that you can't improve and if you
the only real impediment to improving is
someone that doesn't have the humility
to say you know what I think I could
work on being more articulate or you
know what I think I could work on
solving problems and making them more
simple or you know what I'm not that
loud and instead of saying you know what
that's not a good way to lead and said I
say you know what I'm not that loud but
Billy over here is loud so I'm gonna let
him put the word out when it needs to
get put out but if you think that
humility to do that you won't improve as
a leader have you found those people
that even if you lay out what the right
you know skills are that they have to
work on or where their blind spots are
etcetera etcetera that they just can't
whether it's ego or whatever else that
they just can't that you just certain
people you just can't get through to
absolutely it's it's a horrible
situation to be in and in the SEAL Teams
those guys will get fired in the
civilian sector generally those guys get
fired because I mean you go into a
company and you've got a CEO that is not
listening to anyone I'll pour down the
chain you'll not listen to the board not
listen to do subordinates how is he
going to improve he's not going to and
by the way why does he need to improve
he needs to improve because his company
isn't doing well so but this person
might think hey you know I'm great
I'm not gonna learn anything from
anybody I'm just gonna keep doing it my
way
and that guy's not gonna stay in that
job because they don't have the humility
to say you know what I'm probably doing
some things wrong that's why we're not
making money and so I need to change
some of the things that I'm doing so we
can't make money but if you don't have
that attitude and you're not humble yeah
you'll end up getting fired so
conversely have you seen people that
basically had none of the skills that
have been able to overcome it just
through perseverance that just innately
don't have the leadership traits that
don't have you know they don't speak
loud
they aren't clear they can't exist but
just out of sheer sort of force of will
there's there's all these little aspects
that you have you can improve upon right
now you you're not gonna take I'm not
gonna lie to you and say you can take
somebody that has no aptitude for
leadership and they're gonna turn into a
great leader that that's probably not
gonna happen but you can't take someone
that has minimal aptitude for leadership
and they can improve the areas where
they need to improve they can complement
themselves with a team that can cover
for the areas where they're weak and
they can end up doing a great job in a
leadership position for sure yeah so
handing some of this stuff off people
don't think of that
in certain ways when it comes to leaders
like they have to do everything or know
everything or something but actually
hand in some of this stuff off is is
good delegating actually is good oh yeah
absolutely
like for instance big shocker I don't
really like doing paperwork a lot you
know seem odd but I always had guys that
worked for me I'd figure out that guy
that was really good at administrative
stuff and there you go guess what he's
gonna do a bunch of administrative stuff
and that's great and so whatever areas
of weakness you have have something you
know get a member of your team recruit
someone bring someone on board that can
actually make these things happen and
it'll work out great
yeah are you kind of surprised how much
we need leadership sort of in society
right now that we seem to have like a
complete dearth of leadership I mean you
mentioned Jordan Peterson before when I
see the message that he's bringing to
these people it's really about getting
yourself together which is the most I
mean it's very consistent with your
message yeah but but there's but the
people that are coming are sort of
looking for a leader to say that that we
just don't have we seemingly don't have
good leaders right now do you think
that's a fair estimation
we do have good leaders there's plenty
of good leaders out there and I see him
all the time in the business world I
still work with the military and there's
great leaders inside the military
there's great leaders inside the
business world for sure
there's also always a lack of leadership
and I mean I you know on my podcast I
cover I cover books about war generally
first-person accounts and there's a lack
of leadership back then and there's good
leaders so I don't know if it's gotten
any better or worse but the fact of the
matter is that leadership is it's the
hardest thing in the world as far as I
know it's it's the hardest thing you
know people used to ask me when I when I
first got out of the military what was
the most complex you know operation that
you would plan on with like planning
operations isn't a big of a deal like
here's a bad guy here's the assets that
we have here's what we're gonna do to go
take them out I mean this is stuff that
generally it's it's not that hard to do
but the hard part is weeding human
beings and so why does it seem like
there's that we need better leadership
because you always need better
leadership and because leadership is so
hard to actually do properly yeah do you
think we need some sort of mandatory
military service to get some of this
through to young people I think military
service is great for people I know it
was it was great for me and it it worked
out really well for me but I really
don't believe in in mandatory service
because I really don't believe that it's
good for government to tell people what
you need to do yeah I don't really
support that but I definitely support
and encourage everyone to go in the
reserves you know come join that during
the army or the Marine Corps the Navy
Air Force Reserves where you go away for
you know six weeks or eight weeks and
you kind of learn what the military is
about and then you do one weekend a
month and two weeks in the summertime
for you know indefinitely so I think I
have a pretty good handle on your
politics but do you even have a label
that kind of works for you politically I
don't know you I don't know I don't know
what label I think it'd be pretty hard
to label if you were just sort of
summing up sort of your political
beliefs well what would you say I think
that I guess a broad statement would be
I don't think that the government is the
solution to our problems yeah I think
that Jen
unleashing individuals to try and make
things happen is the best way for things
worked it's it's consistent with
decentralized commands that are talking
talked about in the first book that I
wrote with my my brother life is you
can't control everything
you know centralized decision-making
does not work it doesn't work on the
battlefield it doesn't work in business
it doesn't work with governments so
that's you know broadly speaking yeah I
don't think that the government should
control what individuals are doing as
little as possible do there have to be
some rules and regulations in place
absolutely but the framework should be
as loose as possible just like if I'm
running a seal platoon it's not every
man for himself
here's our standard operating procedures
here's the areas where we commit to
disciplined process but then once you
understand those and you know those
you're allowed to operate freely within
those guidelines to execute the mission
and that's what works that's what makes
not just the seal things that's what
makes any good military unit good and
that's what makes good business is good
good businesses aren't good because
someone is micromanaging every single
decision good businesses are good
because people broadly understand the
direction they're heading they
understand that and they're allowed to
move forward as they see fit are you
shocked when you say something like that
which obviously I agree with a hundred
percent I mean all I talk about here is
personal responsibility over and over
that that doesn't seem to sort of be the
kind of flavor of the day at the moment
that with the this if you listen to
mainstream media it's sort of more well
the government should give you this and
we should take from some give to others
that there's a more feeling of you you
were owed something rather than you
gotta get something you're asking if I'm
surprised by that yeah because it
because the the way you're laying it out
it's obvious you know you mean like I
mean that in the best sense it's obvious
like yeah it's your life go go do
something that has value and and creates
the real easy answers no I'm not
surprised by it at all because if I come
here and offer you something for free
why would you not want it why would you
not want to take it if I say hey you can
have this house for free and you'd say
okay that seems like a good deal to me
right and so yeah sure I understand why
people think that sounds like a good
idea because it's something
for free and they want to just in their
own individual world they think okay I
do want to take advantage of this but I
get something for free so it doesn't
surprise me at all the what is
unfortunate is if you can't draw the
line between hey everyone gets
everything for free and there's a price
to that that somebody's gonna have to
pay that's work because there is some
costs hidden in there somewhere
somewhere yeah so tell me what it was
like when he started writing cuz that
must have been a whole other ball of wax
you know it was I was actually an
English major in college and I went to
college halfway through my Navy career I
started off as an enlisted I went to
college and then became an officer then
went to college eventually so and the
reason I was an English major was
because believe it or not when you're an
officer in the military and actually
almost any job in the military you have
to write you not just have to write you
have to read you have to understand
because you have to write concept of
operations documents that are going to
be pushed up the chain of command and
they're gonna read through them and ask
questions and and look at the document
and try and comprehend what it is that
you're trying to do you got to write
evaluations for your troops and your
your troops are getting promoted based
on the evaluations that you write same
with awards you got to write awards same
thing with its after actions reports so
if you do an operation and things don't
go well you have to be able to
articulate and explain that what
happened and then pass that word on so
everyone understands now that you're
you're being given Direction verbal
direction yes of course but you're given
written direction as well you're given
missions in a written format or you're
given rules of engagement in a written
format written by lawyers and I realized
while I was a young enlisted guy and
then as a junior officer what I really
need to be able to do is understand and
communicate well up and down the chain
of command so when I went to college I
said yeah I want to learn English I want
to get good at it and so that's what I
did and so obviously I did a bunch of
writing and a ton of reading when I was
and when I was an English major in
college and then when I was in the
military writing your writing all time
and then when when when I got out and I
was working with these companies and
grew really quickly and that's why my my
buddy who was one of the two commanders
that worked for me in the battle Ramadi
Lake babban
he he was getting out of the Navy too
and you know I said we start I started
need some covering I said a man you want
to want to jump in and get some of this
and he was all on board and then as we
started doing this people would always
say hey you have this stuff written down
anywhere do you have a document you can
give us and so we eventually wrote it
down and then that's how the that's how
the first book came yeah can you lay out
a little bit about the Battle of Ramadi
you basically you sort of wrote the
plans the person that led the battle of
Hammadi that I was in was a guy named
Sean McFarland who was a colonel at the
time he retired as a general just a
super smart incredibly competent and and
great leaders a great leader and he came
in with so I had 40 SEALs with me right
I had 40 seals with me and 60 support
people Colonel MacFarland had 5600 Man
armored Brigade that we supported and we
helped them we work together in the
battle Ramadi vicious fighting very
tough battle and really took a city that
was completely controlled by the
insurgents in 2005/2006
and by early 2007 it was almost
completely pacified so it was it was
incredible it was a kind of incredible
turnaround and an incredible testament
to the capability of you know the US
Armed Forces do you guys pay any
attention to what's going on politically
back home when you're halfway across the
world yes absolutely you have to pay
attention to what's going on politically
back home you know and if especially
like at this time when we deployed to
Ramadi so it's 2005-2006 this is
smack-dab in the middle of the rising
negative public opinion about the war in
Iraq it's also where we had our own
government officials here in America
that we're saying this is unwinnable
this is another Vietnam this is a
quagmire we shouldn't be there to bring
everyone home so yeah you you absolutely
hear those things and that's not good
that's not it's not a positive thing
it's not a positive thing to have your
own government officials in America
saying that you cannot win and meanwhile
you're going out on an operation does
that that must drive you guys crazy more
than anything else
the political elite that often have no
idea what's happening on the ground that
are just spouting off stuff for sure for
sure but as I said it's you listen to it
but you can only pay something so much
attention to it there's so much other
things to focus on I mean you think
about it a little bit but you're not
caught up in the 24-hour news cycle like
you know like people can tend to do here
in America because you're working and
you're getting back from one operation
you're preparing for another operation I
got guys in the field
I got another element in the field I'm
going the field it's you don't have time
to be sitting around hey I wonder what
this politician is saying about what
we're doing how much you have leadership
that you brought to it was just about
managing stress for your guys just
making sure that they were actually okay
in the midst of the chaos yeah
absolutely you have to do some of that I
mean it's it's a it's a balancing act
between all kinds there's all kinds of
things that you're trying to juggle at
the same time and managing stress on the
guys is definitely one of them and in a
situation where you're getting guys
wounded and your guys are getting killed
that stress meter can get pegged out
pretty quick so you have to manage it
you have to do it to the best your
ability that's it's it's hard it's hard
because the war is going to keep going
and you are going to keep you you have
work that needs to continue so the
stress is going to build up on the
troops and it's different for every guy
you know the frontline SEAL or soldier
or marine they're worried about getting
blown up they're worried about getting
shot and killed they're worried about
their friends getting shot killed
they're worried about their friends
getting blown up when you're in charge
of a bunch of guys you're and you're
worried about all those guys and and not
happening to them you're worried about
if we make a mistake if we do something
wrong if we caused some massive
collateral damage that has a negative
strategic impact like that's you have
all those stresses and you know to
control stress what do you do that's
like you look at the things you can't
control the things you can't control
you focus on the things you can't
control and the things that you can't
control you do your best to mitigate and
then you don't worry about because
they'll drive you crazy
yeah what do you make of sort of where
we're at now
having lived through the Iraq war like
was it the right thing to do should we
have done things differently should we
have not just announced we were leaving
one day the whole the whole thing no the
whole thing is that the hindsight is
20/20 and any normal human being can
look back at American history as a whole
and find out all the mistakes that we've
made which are you know infinite right
we make an infinite number of mistakes
and we do the best to try and repair
those once they've taken place the so
for me to look at it from that angle
it's like okay yeah there's all kinds of
mistakes we make as a country we have
make as a country and we will make as a
country mm-hmm
but the best way for me to kind of
rationalize or not even rationalized
because I don't think it needs
rationalization but I when I look at it
from a granular level which is which is
very straightforward we went into a city
the city of Ramadi that was being
controlled by Sikh insurgents the most
sadistic evil subhuman people that you
can imagine they were raping torturing
skinning people alive murdering whole
families beheading people and when we
went in there and again I'm not talking
about we as this small group of seals
I'm talking about when this massive
force of us coalition and Iraqi forces
went into that city and liberated those
people from the torturous and sadistic
control of those insurgents the people
of Ramadi were overjoyed and they would
cheer when we killed insurgents and they
would tell us where insurgents were and
it was a beautiful transition to watch
and it didn't really take place until
after we left but after we left we saw
this it was peaceful
it was literally peaceful they went from
a complete warzone to a to a peaceful
city and where they were they had
markets open the street again they had
kids going school they had girls schools
now you know that's the
there wasn't it in the city of Ramadi
there was schools for girls huh and and
this was just unheard of while the
insurgents were there trying to you know
punish the the populace with their
psychotic brand of of al-qaeda Islam
right and and the the people from body
did not want that at all and so from
that perspective it's like I go to sleep
every night the only regret that I have
is that we couldn't do more because
guess what after America did pull out
Isis took Ramadi and when they got nur
Mahdi and we had friends that were there
Isis went and found the families that
had worked with coalition forces
prevalently and they murdered about five
hundred families so that sickens my
heart that that's horrible so when you
hear that politically it sort of gets
back to over talked about earlier that
you know when they say all right well
we're gonna get out this day like it so
it's got to be over we gotta end this
thing we got to get out to say and you
know that that's counter to what you've
learned sort of on the ground that's
just got to be the worst thing you could
hear yeah one of the work even if you
don't want a conflict to continue first
of all there's no one that wants
conflict less yeah then the people that
have to go and fight it right when when
we sign up for a war it's my friends
yeah and and not just my friends but
it's the military that's gonna go out
and die when when we sign up oh there's
a conflict we need to take care of so
yes we don't want to go to war if you go
to war you go to war to win in the
situation that happened in Iraq we
pulled out completely there was not
there was no one that had fought in Iraq
that thought oh good call that's a great
call there was embers of the inserts the
insurgency had been had been all but
crushed but it had not been completely
extinguished and there were members of
insurgents that were there and as soon
as we pulled out they started growing
and that's what turned into Isis yeah so
that's that's around 2008 ish right yeah
but like that so then what what is sort
of a more sensible way of leaving
something so you could you do a certain
amount of cleanup let's say and you
freeze some of
cities and and good things have happened
but you don't want to be there forever
how do you manage that and with the
stresses of just the political
machinations and all that stuff yeah I
mean that's that's something that you
have to look at every situation that
you're in and you have to say okay well
what can we do here how how much can we
draw down our troops and it's not it's
not a certain amount of time it's not a
certain amount of troops you you have to
look at each situation and do an
assessment and figure out the best way
to move forward and guess what you won't
you won't be perfect and and that's why
an absolute thing like hey we're just
gonna we're not gonna do this anymore is
is a risky move so what do you think's
go so like when Obama did that what do
you think his military leaders who I'm
sure you probably respect some of them
or maybe even know some of them what do
you think they were telling him that
because it's so counter to what you're
laying out here I'm sure they told them
this is not a good idea this is not a
good idea there's like I said there's no
one that had spent time on the ground in
Iraq that said oh you know what we're
good let's leave because it was still a
very very fragile situation yeah and it
looked good it looked good on paper but
you have to give the the the civilian
populace enough time to really kind of
figure out how to live this way because
it's a new way to live yeah you're
oppressed under Saddam then you're
oppressed under some insurgency and to
have that be lifted and then say okay we
look around it's gonna take some time to
figure out how we're gonna do this and
we needed to provide them with enough
security and stabilization that they
could it's not like we were working hard
the last few Lafe who wrote the book
books with me he deployed in 2010 I want
to say they had so what while I was in
Ramadi there was a guy wounded or killed
almost every day for the six months from
here there was a guy wounded or killed
almost every day in the body sometimes
two sometimes five sometimes seven
sometimes one when Lafe went back to a
Lombok province so how am i promised the
the the province that Ramadi is the
capital of in his six-month deployment
there was one fatality for all of
coalition forces it was from a vehicle
rollover Wow
so it was it wasn't like we were over
there gutting it out anymore with the
insurgents the insurgents had been
really really suppressed and we just
needed to give the the locals enough
time to kind of put things together and
start to move forward become stable
politically stable economically stable
and that is what we should have done do
you think it's our moral responsibility
to do actions like this if we can help
people that are living in these horrible
situations that that morally and that we
I mean we the United States have to do
it I think that we have to weigh the
morality of taking care of other people
and taking care of our own people right
so when you and this is a very difficult
decision to make and something I've
talked about on my podcast was the
genocide in Rwanda
so the genocide in Rwanda happened and
there was 800,000 Tutsis that were
killed by Hutus in a hundred days so
this is more efficient than Hitler was
able to pull off and by the way most of
the killing was done 98% of the killing
was done with machetes so this was just
crazy when that was happening I was
sitting off the coast with a in a sealed
platoon on a ship with a bunch of
Marines a bunch of Navy power and we
could have gone in there and done
something and we did and I would say
that the primary reason that we didn't
is because a year earlier Blackhawk down
had happened and we lost a bunch of
servicemembers in Somalia and so I was
like hmm
you know what we don't really want to
get involved in that again and so that's
that what we have to weigh is we have to
weigh what are we willing to lose in
order to save someone else and then what
do we benefit from saving those people
and is that benefit worth the the
expense in money and lives that we
invest into it and sure some of that
benefit is feeling like we can look
ourselves in the mirror as a country
that's part of the benefit part of the
benefit might sure there's economic
benefit sure there's political
but part of the benefit is can we look
in the mirror and say you know what we
almost a million people were butchered
in this country and we didn't do
anything about it that's something that
we have to contend with and that's why
these decisions are hard to make and and
when you do make these commitments as a
country then you need to commit mm-hmm
and not go half-hearted into these
efforts if you're gonna if you're gonna
risk American lives you better be doing
it for a reason that is that merits
putting our our men and women at risk
what do you make of the catch-22 that
America is in with this dilemma all the
time where it's like if we don't do
anything no one does it but then every
time we do do something there's always
the unintended consequences and how long
do we have to be there and everything
else it's really it's a it's a strange
bargain that America's sort of put in or
or put itself in well yeah then this is
this we started off this conversation
talking about leadership and wide
leadership is so hard
leadership is hard because decisions
it's not two plus two equals four it's
it's it's not that at all there's this
insane amount of calculus and and
secondary and tertiary things that
happen after you make a move that you
think is good this is what makes it so
hard and that's why you know for America
as the leader of the free world guess
what
being in that leadership position it's a
hard position to be in and and guess
what just like a leader just like when I
was a leader when I was a leader of a
SEAL team when I was leader of a SEAL
task unit did I do everything perfect
absolutely not I made mistakes I made
mistakes I made mistakes when people
died and that is the burden of
leadership that you bear and so as a
nation we're in the same situation the
things that we do we are not going to do
things perfectly we have to do them with
the best intent which I believe we do
but things aren't going to go perfectly
and guess what some people are gonna be
mad when you make those mistakes some
people are gonna be mad
even when you do things right they're
gonna look at you and say oh you should
have done that that was the wrong thing
to do
okay here's what we weighed out and
you've got to be willing to take those
criticisms leadership leadership is a
very hard thing so what do you make of
the guy in the White House now related
to leadership because even if we
just to look at Iraq so it's like
alright George W Bush got us into Iraq
you can argue whether that was good or
bad or whatever Obama got us out and as
you just laid out maybe the way we got
out was probably not the right way to do
it it doesn't seem that from at least
what I could tell that Trump is looking
to get us into extra Wars or anything
like that well it certainly doesn't seem
like he's looking to get us into any
extra worse I would agree with that and
again there's I don't believe that hey
we're gonna be an isolationist nation
and we're not gonna play on the world
stage I don't think that's the best
thing the other end of the spectrum is
hey we're gonna go fight and police up
the world that's not the right thing
either the right thing is to look at
each situation as it unfolds in the
world and make try and make the best
decisions you can as a leader at that
time and and again these are not easy
decisions to make these are these are
decisions that that you make them and
they still unfold the day after you make
a decision the minute after you make a
decisions things unfold that you didn't
expect that you didn't anticipate and
yet you made a decision so now you've
got to make another decision and and
it's it's a challenge what do you make
of him just as a leader if we were
looking at the gray the way you would
grade a leader how would you look at
Trump from a leadership perspective yeah
I think Trump is an interesting
characteristic of some really broad
extremes right so he does things that I
say oh good move and then literally 20
minutes later 20 minutes later I'll be
thinking myself what what how can you
even think that this is a decent thing
to do right and and by that I mean you
know jumping out on Twitter and
criticizing some kind of person some
some individual human celebrity or
celebrity yeah hey what are you doing
why are you doing that you know so I
think the guy who was it that just you
the the the testimony that just took
place Michael Cohen yeah
so Michael Cohen gets up and says that
Trump is a bad character
and I'm like okay you know I mean this
is this to me is not a surprise but I
don't think this is a big surprise
anyone yeah this is not this is a guy
that he's not the guy that you want your
daughter to marry at least least I don't
want my daughters to marry someone like
that okay so what's this character like
not the one that we want to model
ourselves after do we want do we expect
do we want a leader to be someone that
we can look up to and model ourselves
after absolutely absolutely we want to
look at a look at our leader and say wow
I really respect that person and I want
to follow them and I'm gonna emulate
their their actions and their behavior
that's that's absolutely that's what a
leader is yeah so does Trump fall short
on that oh yes he does oh yes he does so
it's a it's a strange world that we live
in that that guy versus Hillary Clinton
who he ran against neither one of those
people are people that that you look at
and say seems that could seems like a
character I want to emulate that's what
I'm looking towards I want to be that
person I want to I want to move in that
direction you know from the 300 plus
million people in America those are the
two candidates that we put forward what
is wrong with us
yeah that's a problem well what is wrong
with us what do you think the answer to
that is it's not just the way the
political system set up or is that the
media or is that us is it I think it
also is a political system for sure I
think it has to do with the the way that
the way that media is and the way
celebrity is that the the name is able
to carry itself the character the
Britnie self branding that goes out I
think drives so much of this that we're
not really we're not really assessing
what type of leader this person is going
to be we're assessing how popular
they're so for a guy that talks about
discipline a lot when you see Trump
tweeting is that what's going on in your
head you're like man this is just a
discipline thing like you get some of
these things right and if you could just
discipline yourself in another way yeah
I would say that I thought when when
Trump won the election and I was just as
surprised as anyone when Trump won the
election I thought okay well you know
what at least now we're gonna get
step up an act presidential all that
what did it take 15 minutes before you
looked at it said okay guess okay it's
gonna take him a little bit longer than
I thought but but it hasn't changed and
it was the same thing you see Hillary
Clinton do the same types of things
where you doing behavior that you'd say
yourself why are you doing that you
don't do that you don't do those kind of
things you don't behave that way and so
I think you just have to you know we
have to kind of gut through I hope that
this is a situation where this is a
point a pivot point for the country
where we'll start looking around and
saying okay we don't really want to do
that uh-huh we want to look for the
right person that's gonna do this job
correctly that's gonna represent the
country well and are you worried that we
don't get out of this whatever this
thing is that everyone can sort of feel
and no one knows exactly what what it is
just this this endless bickering and how
it seems like social media is making us
all hate each other and you don't that
we don't have real at least at the
political level leaders to look up to if
you're looking for self-discipline and
morality and whatever you know what
people I had people write when Trump got
elected you know people would just fly
off the handle with me right and and I
don't really talk about politics very
often and the reason that I don't talk
about politics very often is because
well because from a leadership
perspective if I'm trying to get you to
do something the worst way to lead is
for me to bark at you and tell you what
to do that's not good leadership so I
don't do that with people that I
communicate with I don't say hey he's
he's horrible and she's great or she's
horrible and he's gonna I don't say that
I just I just give examples from history
about the way good leaders behave and
the way bad leaders behave and let
people make their own decisions but
somebody was hitting me up hey you know
you need to you need to speak out and
you know I said okay well here's my
speech America is stronger than one man
America is stronger than one man America
is stronger than any one individual
politician we're we're a massive you
know massive ship and
of ship takes a long time to turn and
the checks and balances that are in
place inside the government which are
sometimes really really bureaucratic and
and disappointing and aggravating
because it's so hard to change things
they're they're hard to change for a
reason
so am I worried that this is that this
tipping point won't come no it'll come
eventually because eventually free
people the free people of America won't
allow for things to go so far in one
direction it were so far in the other
direction we won't allow ya now what
makes it hard to reach that tipping
point is because America it's so it's so
beautiful in America right there's
there's it's such a stress free life
right it's just there's you know we were
in the middle of two wars and mmm that
didn't affect the average American in
any way whatsoever but not even the oil
prices like nothing affected them they
were still driving their SUV to
Starbucks and ordering a latte with zero
impact and that was when we were
fighting two wars and losing people
every day on those battlefields it was
no factor so what happens in America is
we we pretty much don't care as long as
we're comfortable but if things start to
get uncomfortable
that's what I think the the real tipping
point will come and there'll be a
backlash one way or the other
yeah all right I want to shift off some
of the war stuff but very quickly so
since you mentioned the two wars the one
that nobody ever talks about or even
thinks about is Afghanistan which I
think now it's the it's the longest war
we've ever been in right I mean this is
the longest war it's still ongoing now
it seems to me that nobody knows really
why we're there or why this is so
ongoing what what the hell should we be
doing or thinking about or we it's never
discussed period yeah and it's
interesting because this is something
when when Trump if you remember Trump
said hey what's the plan and he got a
bunch of pushback and people were saying
no who's he to ask and I was like well
he's the president and so yeah you need
some kind of a plan you need some kind
of a goal and I do think that needs
clearer definition in Afghanistan of
what it is we're trying to make happen
what does that look like you know from
my perspective when you get into these
country
where you're trying to build something
or trying to you're not trying to build
yourself you're trying to allow them to
be free that's what you're really trying
to make happen you're trying to allow
these countries to be free they're not
going to be the same as us that's one
thing that I'm fairly confident about
there's different cultures that are
going to adopt freedom and democracy in
a different way and you can't impose
what we think it should be like on other
cultures because it doesn't match up
perfectly but it can match up pretty
well and individual human beings in
these countries you know what they want
they want a job they want to build a
little business they want to be able to
feed their kids they want their kids to
have a better opportunity than they do
that's what when you can when you can
provide some of that that will start to
take hold and when you provide some of
it other people in that country will
look out it goes hmm that seems to be a
pretty good deal over there I would like
to try that too and pretty soon you can
get freedom and democracy the attitude
of it to to expand and so it takes a
long time you know the average
counterinsurgency is seven years but
they can take really really long time
but in my opinion and really through the
history of the world eventually in my
mind eventually through history
eventually the free individual will rise
to the top and and and and they will
rule themselves and so you have to give
that opportunity for individual freedom
you they have to have the opportunity to
grow and to take root
take good solid root and to grow and be
strong enough that when tyranny comes
along it can't just wipe it out because
tyranny can wipe out the individuals
without probably we've seen that in
history - tyranny can wipe out and
destroy individual freedoms and
individual really individual aspirations
they can just be mopped up and destroyed
by tyranny so you have to give free
and individual freedom not just the time
to sprout up a little bit you got to
give it the time to take root because
once people have tasted true freedom and
true opportunity they don't give it up
and that's what I think you have to do
you have to stay somewhere long enough
that people understand what true freedom
is they recognize that it's theirs to
protect and it has to be rooted strong
enough that it can't be white washed
away by tyranny so then going all the
way back so what what are we doing in
Afghanistan I mean do you sense that
that's actually happening there because
it's something like 14 years or
something yeah and it's one of these
things where we oscillate too much on
what it is that we're trying to
accomplish and what we're willing to
sacrifice to accomplish it because you
know from an isolationist perspective
from a from a okay let's just take up
America take care of America oh let's
take the Taliban oh you want to live in
like a world you want your country to be
you know back in the Stone Age
and that's how you want to live okay
cool we'll be over here doing our thing
like that's that's the yeah that's
that's a that's a legitimate plan hey
you guys want to live in the Stone Age
cool we'll be over here with iPhones
that's fine we don't care but then it's
like okay but we're gonna breed Terrace
but okay well we'll come in here caged
me and knock those guys out how's that
okay we could do that and that's if
that's the plan okay let that be the
plan what if we're gonna stay there if
we're gonna try and get freedom to take
group which I believe is the best thing
to do because I do believe that we do
have some level of moral obligation to
try and support individual freedom
throughout the world that's that's to me
that's pretty self-evident does that
mean that we have to jump into
everywhere that there's oppression no
doesn't and we can and it also means
that inside those countries the human
beings inside those countries also has a
moral obligation to rise up and fight on
their own and that was nice about going
back to Iraq was you know I've got
friends that fought and in Mosul as I
took Mosul back but those aren't Iraqi
troops
and we're moving from building to
building taking massive casualties as a
matter of fact one of my friends that
was there said there was a in the
beginning of the Mosel campaign the
Americans we're looking at each other
saying hey these guys are taking so many
casualties we're gonna run out of Iraqi
soldiers like they're all gonna die and
the Iraqi soldiers continue to go
forward and they continue to fight and
they ended up you know getting the upper
hand and so when they say that that we
were greeted as liberators it actually
is true oh yeah yeah oh my god I mean in
Mosul oh it was and again I wasn't there
and I never fought in Afghanistan either
but the guys coming back from bosal
though the people were absolutely just
they were they were they were being I
mean everything enslaved beheaded
tortured everything it was absolutely it
was heinous yeah it was it was it was a
heinous war crime across the board so
yeah absolutely so we're all right we've
done a lot sort of out of our borders
here but it's interesting you mentioned
that you know in the mid we can be in
the middle of all of these Wars and yet
we can still get a latte and we can
still pay no attention to it and live
our good lives do you think there's a
risk to our freedom here because of that
that we've got it so frickin good that
we almost don't know what freedom is
anymore do I think it's an actual risk
no no I don't I think that the minute
things the minute you start really
talking about taking away the personal
freedoms of Americans there will be real
problems so okay the is that a risk sure
that could that could be a risk I see
that as a real small chance that things
get bad enough where where mass groups
of Americans say oh yeah we're not we're
not we're not we're not doing that you
just cross the line you know the the
American Revolution right oh you want to
raise tea taxes no actually we're gonna
find a war against you you're not
raising the tea taxes right that's could
it get to that point here sure but you
got to remember what's going to be
sacrificed and you know that's one of
the coolest things about the American
Revolution is the people that fought it
were the people that actually had the
most of
the people that stood up so it would
take it would take a lot but I'm I I
don't I think it would take a lot to get
there I think it would take a lot to get
there and if it gets there that'll be
sad it'll be a sad day but I believe
that freedom would prevail
all right let's let's shift all together
to sort of what you're doing now so
podcasting writing all that stuff having
these kind of conversations it's kind of
cool that that people are paying
attention to this stuff now isn't it
we're when you started doing the podcast
was that just sort of you were just
gonna throw it out there and see what
happens and see if oh wow people might
want to listen to long-form conversation
yeah I did a podcast with Tim Ferriss
and when he press stopped on the
recorder he said you should do your own
podcast and I Joe Rogan heard it and led
me on so I was on Joe Rogan's podcast in
the middle of that podcast i rung it
said you should have your own podcast so
Tim Ferriss and Joe Rogan tell you to
have a podcast did have a plaque can you
listen so I did and for me it's a it's a
it's a great medium I always when I grew
up I grew up listening to radio shows
and so I always liked listening to radio
and that's essentially what it is is
radio without commercials and I get to
talk about things that I'm interested in
and and again you know the the advice
some of the advice that I got when I
started off was like oh you need to have
guests all the time people are getting
tired of you don't don't talk about
these dark you know don't talk about
these dark violent things all you can't
talk about war all the time and you need
to keep them shorter and all this and I
didn't listen to anybody and my podcasts
are really long some of them are
extremely heavy and dark and talked
about some of the worst in fact I think
we've covered most of the really the
worst things that have unfolded on the
planet and they're long and I don't have
a lot of guests you know I do have
guests but I don't have a lot of guests
so the interesting thing is yes
shockingly enough people people listen
to it and did the connection and the
feedback is is awesome yeah how do you
think it's changed you by going to all
those dark places and talking about all
this stuff and and expressing your ideas
and all that well I've gotten I've
gotten a lot
I've got a lot of experience out of it
the experience I get out of it is I so I
do a lot of book cover a lot of
historical books like I said
first-person accounts of war and
atrocity in that when I first started
the podcast I said well you know I
probably got I'll probably five because
I got like five books that really had an
impact on me so I'll cover those books
and then whatever that will probably it
and then I said you know there was one
more book that I really want to throw in
this pot and then there was another one
any what it didn't take but you know
five or six more podcasts where I said
I'm never gonna be able to do enough
podcast to cover the things that I want
to talk about and that's the way it's
been so I've read I read basically a
book a week for the last three years and
you know I I finished doing all the
books that I that I actually you had
already read yeah I'm like I'm in like I
don't know so you're like I better write
some then yeah well I'd already written
my first book when the podcast came out
uh-huh
so so how has it changed me and the
other the other great thing is I get to
interact with all these people and
people come up and I know they do this
to you - people come up to me and they
say I know I feel like I know it's weird
but I feel like you know me and I'm like
yeah you do know me because how I am on
the podcast is actually how I am that's
just me and and then I tell them that I
actually know them too because if
they've listened to me for 500 hours
yeah you haven't spent 500 hours
listening to you know I mean it's like
that's just not happening
yeah so I do know them and then they
gave great feedback and I learn a lot
from from the books that I read from the
people that I have had on and from the
feedback that I get and hey read this
book look at this aspect so it's made me
it's made me learn a lot so from first
person war books and all your life
experience how do we end up with we got
two of them here I think yeah children's
books
yeah yeah yeah right here well so
there's the dragon yeah yeah I might say
dragon so yeah yeah I didn't I didn't
write
I didn't I didn't I didn't give Jordan
any credit for it you know it's called
Nike the Dragons Jordan sorry
yeah I got four kids and as I started
continuing to hear back from people that
were listening to what I was saying and
the one I'd hear a lot is I wish I had
this when I was a kid I wish I had this
when I was a kid and of course my answer
would be like I do too I wish I had the
lessons from extreme ownership when I
was a kid I wish I had the lessons from
the discipline equals freedom Field
Manual I was a kid absolutely
and growing up or watching my own
children grow up I just knew that the
things that I tried to impart on them I
figured I could put into stories where I
could impart those values onto little
kids and make their lives easier and
better and that's it so I started
writing them and it was surprising that
at the the response the response has
been you know people love them and you
know one of my favorite letters I've
gotten is I got this letter from this
guy who you know he's saying I'm 37
years old and I was drinking and I was
overweight and I was doing they hadn't
been promoted and I got all these
problems going on his life and he he
said then I read your book and I said
okay I'm gonna wake up a little bit
early okay I'm gonna start working out
okay I'm gonna stop complaining okay and
he went through his whole letter and how
now he had lost 52 pounds and he had
been promoted and he'd stopped drinking
and all this stuff and then the last
line said the book I read was the way of
the warrior kid which is you know aimed
at kids but the lessons in there are
completely universal and applied to your
whole life so it's been it's been great
and I get a lot of social media posts of
little kids studying flashcards because
you know the premise of the warrior kids
story is that there's a little kid who's
you can't do any pull-ups he doesn't
know how to swim
he's getting picked on by the school
bully Kenny Williamson and he doesn't
know his times tables and the last day
of school ends and he's all sad and then
he remembers that his uncle Jake is
coming to stay with him for the summer
and his uncle Jake was in the SEAL Teams
so his uncle JT comes to stay and
first day says hey you know what you
want to do tomorrow and do something you
want go for a swim and the kid goes oh
no no to swim and I don't know how to
goes you know I don't know my time set
was getting picked on so the uncle says
look these aren't problems we can solve
all these gets him into jujitsu classes
teach them how to swim teaches them how
to study using flash cards and other
memorization techniques and teaches them
how to eat right teaches him to work out
and the kid turns turns around and so
that's that one Mikey and the Dragons is
about facing your dragons and little kid
that's scared of everything and he finds
a book under his bed and it opens it up
quickly and there's a bunch of pictures
in it that looks scary of dragons and
fire and so he doesn't want to read it
but there's also a picture in there of a
little kid that looks confident and like
he knows what he's doing
so he says alright you know I'm gonna
read this book and then you turn the
page in this book and you are now
looking at the cover of this next book
which is called the dragon Prince and
that's the story of a kingdom where the
king had died and now there was no one
to defend the kingdom from the dragons
except for this little seven year old
prince and so he's scared he goes to get
his father's sword and his father shield
opens up this big war chest and in there
he pulls out the sword it's too heavy
for him he pulls out the shield it's too
heavy for him and he's even more scared
now and then he sees a note at the
bottom of the war chest and he pulls it
out and it's a note from his father the
king who explains to him what he needs
to do to stand up and face the Dragons
the story continues on so I enjoy
storytelling yeah well I sense I sense
an animated movie and I guess the last
thing I got free is what do you do to
relax after all this after all the work
and everything else and it's a pretty
intense life that you're living yeah I'm
guessing you're gonna say working out
but give me something else well work
does that include jujitsu
yeah well that's still within the
working out that thing but whatever
works for you you know I surf I do
jujitsu I hang out with my kids play
guitar and yeah I find this stuff
relaxing it's enjoyable for me too -
right it's enjoyable for me to talk to
people about leadership and go out with
my company excellent front and teach and
align executives on leadership and watch
them be able to turn their company
around or bring their company to the
next level based 100% on leadership
which is what I tell them I say look
you've got this problem you got that
problem you've got another problem every
problem that you have inside your
organization is a leadership problem I
guess that means you slayed the dragons
and you're doing the right thing in life
it's been a pleasure man we finally were
able to do this and for more on Jocko
you can follow them on twitter at Jocko
willing
[Music]